popularized by films like Alfred
Hitchcock's 1948 thriller rope and made
famous by recent hits like 2014's Oscar
winner Birdman long takes where the
director follows the narrative with a
single shot for the length of an entire
scene or longer can now be found
everywhere some are nearly invisible
unless you know what you're looking for
while others are masterful tour de
force's meant to grab the audience's
attention here are some of our favorite
long takes from film and television
along with our take on what makes them
so special Raiders of the Lost Ark it's
only 96 seconds but the scene
introducing the character of Marion
Ravenwood in Steven Spielberg's 1981
adventure film Raiders of the Lost Ark
is a classic example of what's come to
be known as a Spielberg 1er with a few
notable exceptions Spielberg Waters tend
to be unobtrusive you don't realize
you're even looking at a long take in
many cases the one from Raiders is
particularly noteworthy because it does
such a great job of introducing the
audience to Marion while also adding
some tension to the drinking contest and
heightening the hilarity of her
opponents eventual collapse true
detective while well executed long take
tracking shots have long been featured
in movies in recent years they've
started to pop up in television
productions more frequently in 2014 HBO
sat the bar during season 1 episode 4 of
their crime anthology drama true
detective starring Matthew McConaughey
and Woody Harrelson directed by Cary
Joji Fukunaga the six-minute long take
at the end of the episode follows
McConaughey through a complex scene
involving a gang robbery gone wrong
several shootouts a hostage taking in
chase through multiple houses and an
escape over a fence into a waiting
vehicle it's an amazing take in a great
episode one that propelled true
detective into the mainstream earning
Fukunaga and the rest of the crew
multiple Primetime Emmy Awards wins and
nominations Game of Thrones in battle of
the Basterds the ninth episode of season
6 on the hit HBO series Game of Thrones
director Miguel subhanak pulled off a
long take tracking shot following
protagonist Jon Snow as he navigates
through a pitched battle between his
army and Ramsay Bolton's forces clocking
in at 60 seconds it gives audiences a
visceral and bloody look inside a
frenetic battle making it perhaps one of
the most realistic depictions of a
medieval clash between armies audiences
and critics alike loved the episode it
remains one of the highest rated by
viewers on IMDB and it won a
record-setting 7
Primetime Emmy Awards old boy not only
is the hallway fight scene from Park
chan-wook's 2003 noir thriller oldboy
one of the best action sequences to be
found anywhere it's also an impressive
three minute long take the
cinematography isn't anything complex
the motion of the camera simply slides
sideways following star Choi Min cheek
as he advances down a hallway while
beating up a group of thugs
however the simplicity works especially
when paired with the gritty surroundings
and simple fighting techniques the
scenes reminiscent of old beat him up
arcade games like Double Dragon
if Double Dragon allowed you to take on
dozens of bad guys at once and bash
their heads in with a claw hammer
gravity already known for his
groundbreaking long take car scene from
2006 as children of men Alfonso cuarón
one-upped himself with the release of
the 2013 science fiction thriller
gravity the film opens with an amazing
17 minute long take beginning with a
stunning view of Earth from orbit and
ending with Sandra Bullock's astronaut
flung away into the blackness of outer
space while cuarón won't give away all
the secrets behind the making of this
shot we do know the crew created a
special cage like lighting rig which was
able to rotate lights around the actors
at high speed to give the illusion they
were spinning or flipping in zero
gravity no matter how it was achieved
there's no question that this long take
will remain cuarón's calling card for a
long while until he raises the bar yet
again the secret in their eyes directed
co-written produced and edited by
Argentinian filmmaker Juan Jose
Campanella the 2009 crime drama the
secret in their eyes won an Oscar for
Best Foreign Language Film and for good
reason the film features several long
takes including a visually stunning
5-minute shot that begins with an aerial
view of a packed soccer stadium before
closing in on the main characters in the
crowd and following them Steadicam style
as they pursue a suspect through its
underbelly and finally out on the field
itself awesome weekend in his 1967 black
comedy weekend french director jean-luc
Godard presented the audience with a
thoroughly unlikable couple so uncaring
that they each plan to murder the other
in order to escape their relationship
before they can do that however they
need to take a cross-country trip to
secure a pending inheritance as the
embittered pair embark on their journey
however they and the film itself are
interrupted by a massive traffic jam
along a country road orchestrated
masterfully by Godard the crowd of cars
scene
to stretch for almost a mile and takes
the bickering couple nearly eight
minutes of screen time to navigate as
they illegally pass an essentially road
rage their way through when we finally
reach the cause of the holdup a
horrifyingly bloody car accident the
ruthlessness of the couple becomes
evident as they and the camera speed
pass without a pause relieved to finally
get on with the rest of the movie at any
cost
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]